it's 11 a.m. in the morning I'm making
fried mashed potatoes and there's
nothing you can do to stop me
no Marcel beep no no no you know your
life is different now I had an idea with
the Thanksgiving of it all coming up
that I wanted to make fried mashed
potato balls
I am PMSing so you're right and I went
online I looked up fried mashed potato
balls and there's a billion recipes and
I didn't look at a single one of them
because ignorant bliss stupidity is
blessed put it on a pillow
sit on it fart on all of it I have some
idea in my head of how to do this and I
didn't want to be influenced by other
people's successful tried and true
recipes I wanted to try it on my own
truly and here we are I'm already
overwhelmed okay so I went to the store
I got instant mashed potatoes some eggs
I also got some instant stuffing because
I might try to make some fried stuffing
balls too I think years and years and
years ago I tried to make fried stuffing
no I tried to make fried salad I don't
remember I've probably tried to make
something very similar to this in the
past but it's now the future so we're
maybe doing it again I didn't know if I
wanted to do instant mashed potatoes or
homemade mashed potatoes so currently I
have two potatoes chopped up boiling in
a pot back there for the potential that
that works I figure I'll make the
instant mashed potatoes and the stuffing
and then we'll go from there and see
what our best options are if this works
this is like a really cute way to take
your Thanksgiving leftovers and make
them cute and worse for you next week is
the week we all officially agree to give
up that's a favorite thing about
Thanksgiving so first things first we're
gonna make these instant mashed potatoes
I don't know if I've ever made instant
mashed potatoes hey dork I'm not gonna
make a ton because I'm a monster we're
into two thirds cup of water also by the
way last night I did an at-home food
allergy test super fun but I had to
prick both my ring fingers and it's
really fun and appetizing to watch the
person with two kind of gross band-aids
on their fingers manipulate food with
their hands two thirds cup water 1/4
teaspoon of salt one tablespoon butter I
only have
sea salt left in my house because I'm an
[ __ ] right that seems right I got I
can't believe it's not butter light
because I'm a perfect okay do I think
that was gross what I just did so now
we're gonna put this on the stovetop and
I'm gonna eat it to a boil but that's
going okay now um I thought it had this
like figured out planned out I guess I
did it I went on the side of this that
you can microwave this stuffing that's
trash taste levels right there and I'm
all for it so that's what we're gonna do
here
we need a microwave safe oh damn it are
you Mike website I have very minimal
bowls I'm gonna assume that you are
because you can't spell assume without
me so we combined the stuffing mix one
and a half cups of hot water hello I
would like to enter you and that's how
you asked for consent four tablespoons
of butter great oh great job everybody
I was gross so this is boiling our
waters ah okay the water's boiling so
we're gonna put in 2/3 a cup of the
potato mixture
oh my pricked fingers a couple tricks
two thirds of a cup snowing one third
give it there's a third cup of milk now
we have to stir it whoa Wow and just
like that there potatoes cool yeah it's
English what I'm even trying to do with
that way because I love trying I'm gonna
be an impatient [ __ ] and put this in
the freezer to let it cool down before
we try and deep-fry it because that
seems like a thing everything smells
like burning let's handle our stuffing
now got water hot water does it really
need to be hot it's gonna go to
microwave I'll use this water and use
some of the potato water I'm combining
it with regular cold water
welcome to disgusting kitchen grace
Helbig okay now I put in the microwave
for 5 to 6 minutes this seems wrong
that's gonna do its thing for a second
okay I'm gonna recollect my everything
and be right back anything's have gone
on one I made a really cute workstation
for myself dude these stuff being is
finishing the
wave and I put that in the freezer do
you know expedite my impatient [ __ ]
Nestor eat the mashed potatoes though
you them have cooled down enough and
tastes great by the way we've created a
little frying station here I have flour
eggs and breadcrumbs again didn't look
up any recipes didn't want anyone else's
influence I think this is how you fry
things and now I'm gonna fill a little
skillet with some oil heat it up and
we're gonna get to making some balls and
frying them up and using vegetable oil
I don't know I'm using vegetable oil
because it's literally all I have cause
I forgot about the oil part of the
frying part of you know them just a
major part of this recipe when I was out
buying ingredients also we have forgone
the homemade mashed potatoes part of
this I'll make them for myself as mashed
potatoes but you should you know do what
you want for yourself all the time
forever as long as you're not hurting
anyone that's my entire piece of life
advice let's check on our stuffing
how are you new oh it went everywhere
that was gross what I just did I know it
you know it I remember one time seeing
on Rachael Ray's 30-minute meals that
you know that oil is ready to fry things
in when you put the end of a wooden
spoon in it and bubbles create around
the the penetration of this wood and the
warm oils okay let's see if we can do
this okay ready let's just do it I'm
touching it my hands are clean I've
washed them within the last week we're
gonna form a little ball we're gonna
roll it in some flour I don't know if
this part is necessary and then we're
gonna put it in the egg mixture and then
we're gonna put in the breadcrumbs
okay we got a something let's keep going
you imagine when you host Thanksgiving
the next day everyone's wildly hungover
and you got some flour some eggs some
breadcrumbs and some leftover mashed
potatoes and you make this [ __ ] for
everyone you will get the best Christmas
gifts or whatever holiday gifts you
celebrate I mean that's at least what
you deserve if these are great these
might give me salmonella
I don't know well do just a couple
or because what's the point of making a
lot if they're all bad
my philosophy right now it's ducted
making YouTube you wondered how I handle
balls come on this is also a great way
to explain how babies are made
ball full of mashed potatoes combines
with some egg and you cook it for a
little bit well a lot you got something
you got to take care of for 18 years you
guys look great
what's better than having two band-aids
on your fingers while you cook having
two wet band-aids on your fingers while
you cook let's see how this oils doing
oh we got bubbles it's time to put it in
the oil y'all here we go oh wow because
I am making this up on the fly and I
haven't consulted other recipes I have
no idea how long they keep them in the
oil for we're gonna turn them over I
guess until they if they're tan on so if
I'm thinking about cooking its how
stressful it is sometimes whoa these are
frying fast dang they got golden-brown
within seconds I'm gonna take them out
and put them on a paper towel to pull
down they cooked faster and better than
I anticipated before they fully cooled
down is I have these like parsley flakes
I'm just gonna sprinkle some of them on
to make it look interesting guys I'm so
excited for your Thanksgiving hangover
look at this beauty we're gonna do the
same thing for the stuffing now and see
what the happens and this is good for
vegetarians I don't know what am I
trying to sell you on are you not
entertained into the hot pan holy [ __ ] I
think I did something great that's what
I would say at my climax that went
really well these look amazing and the
fun thing is you can't really tell which
ones which so there's some opportunities
for some fun harmless pranks I did heat
up some canned gravy that I was gonna
pour on top of this because she do it
oh this is gross this might not be the
right choice let me show you up close
wow wow wow just a bunch of glazed
doughnut psych
you get yourself a savory hangover cure
potentially okay now it's the time of
truth because everything's gonna lie up
until now let's taste these there's the
fried mashed potato ball you know it's
delicious it's [ __ ] delicious sue me
if you make this and you don't think
it's delicious
that's delicious okay so yeah you will
be a god if you make this the day after
Thanksgiving with your leftovers let me
try this stuffing yeah boiler bread on
bread it's [ __ ] great back fantastic
oh my god I did it I had an idea I
execute it and I made it and it worked
and I don't feel like I should have this
level of confidence surging through my
veins right now to be fair it's probably
just a bunch of I can't believe it's not
better
low calorie but either way I feel crazy
amped if you guys make this which I
fully encourage you to do because this
actually was relatively easy compared to
you know my cooking experience in the
past let me know tag me show me Holly
yours turned out subscribe to this
YouTube channel I make videos whenever I
get up PMSing wild hair for carbs you
never know when that's gonna be
thank you so much for watching um I
don't know even if you don't celebrate
Thanksgiving or it's not your
Thanksgiving season
look at you Canada this is just an
amazing thing to make for a meal on this
is wonderful I am still in a slight
state of shock that this actually worked
out relatively effortlessly I'm thankful
for my brain oh yeah
doesn't move them hey grace I'm proud of
you thank you